major developments in day two of jury
deliberations in the kyle rittenhouse
trial the 12 jurors just finished
re-watching video evidence in the
courtroom from the night of the
shootings that happened as the defense
pushes once again for a mistrial
claiming prosecutors withheld key video
evidence and the media ramping up their
attacks on the judge in the case
i don't see how anybody can say that
this judge
is not biased and is not leaning in a
certain direction he's shielding cal
ringhouse treating him as if he's a
child this judge threw out what many
people believed would be the one uh
charge that he would be convicted of his
phone going off with like the song that
gets played at trump's eyes but we won't
we won't go into that too deeply what
about the judge involving
and drawing those numbers i've never
seen that never granted
does it happen never i've never ever
ever seen that before
but judge bruce schroeder isn't taking
their crap calling out the media and
saying he'll think twice about live
broadcasting one of his trials
when i talked about
problems with the media when this trial
started
we were there in part not fully but in
part because of grossly irresponsible
handling
of what comes out of this trial i will
tell you this
i'm going to think long and hard about
live television a trial again next time
so greg he's right about the way the
media has covered this but don't you
think it's essential that the trial was
broadcast so people can watch it
themselves without the media filter
because the media would say something
well it's funny people are watching it
and there still is a segment of
media
baldly lying about what's happening
sellers especially it's just full of
falsehoods i think we're at a stage
where every juror that
takes part in a trial will have to be
placed in witness relocation after the
trial because the media in a frothing
activist class puts them in danger
because they see his violence as an
appropriate response if the jury doesn't
come back with the with the decision
that they want so the media perpetuates
this cycle right if there's riots they
will call them mostly peaceful which
then puts the cops on notice right that
you better not harm these peaceful
protesters holding their molotov
cocktails and then they will
deliberately like those clowns ignore
the facts of the case uh bury the truth
about jacob blake uh the truth about the
men that ridden house or the non-men
that written house killed in order to
make sure that there is
um there is trouble later i'm not
rooting for anything but justice so i
will live with whatever outcome there is
but the media places a lower bar for the
activist class they believe that their
behavior can include any kind of
violence uh no matter what i said this
uh and i said it yesterday to the
audible gasps a month ago when i talked
about the choven verdict that i was
relieved that my that chovin was found
guilty because my neighborhood would not
be torched it was a commentary on this
and how the justice system is now being
held hostage by threats of mayhem
because the media will allow the
activists to riot for that reason yeah
dana the judge has received a number of
threats as a result of this trial well
and that might just be a little bit of a
sign of the times um in our first block
we were talking about um your passions
that then also become all sound like
threats and then all of a sudden the fbi
is involved and the judge i understand
why they don't want cameras in the
courtroom because in some ways it just
is a distraction and it could put the
jury in jeopardy or make them perhaps
change their minds but i also think that
the trial being on television helped a
lot of people understand
what was actually happening that night
why did kyle rittenhouse feel threatened
was it self-defense if you had well and
you just think what if it wasn't on
television where the prosecution's
witness admits that he had a gun pointed
at kyle rittenhouse right
so without that we wouldn't have known
and i think that so i think that's good
i'm very interested in this whole
process of there's a mistrial motion
and
when the judge can make a decision and
that also includes
even if they find him guilty they could
he could go back and say mistrial then
the prosecution has to start all over we
don't know what's going to happen but
watch that very closely so geraldo can
you comment on that with your legal
expertise on why the mistrial motion was
filed again there was one filed
previously in the trial because the
prosecution withheld evidence of high
quality videos the jury had seen the
video before but it was low quality and
you're supposed to submit the most high
quality version of the evidence i think
what the
defense is indicating is that they would
have proceeded in a different way if
they had that vivid
high quality video and knew more
precisely what their client did i think
that a couple of things i i think that
on the basis of the defense moving for a
mistrial without prejudice which means
the state would have a do-over
that that
doesn't seem that they have a lot of
confidence in their case for the defense
to do that why would they want a
mistrial without president a do-over if
they thought they were winning right now
so you know i'm starting to feel a
little uh
that and the fact that the the
deliberations are now being uh being
prolonged but remember uh when i was
starting in the news business uh decades
ago there was a guy named warner wolf
was the sports guy said let's go to the
videotape
nowadays because of like body cams on
cops and surveillance cameras everywhere
and drones with cameras
people
the jurors are discounting the physical
testimony and are
asking to be their own witnesses by
looking at the videotape themselves and
making a determination what they see did
written house uh provoke
uh you know uh the uh the first victim
rosenbaum or was he merely trying to
defend himself so if you see in the
video tape if
indeed uh rittenhouse is pointing the
gun first and then the whole thing
happens it's different than if rose
obama is in his face crazy so jesse
there's the issue too is that the
prosecution got berated by the judge
multiple times during the trial for
trying to introduce evidence had already
been thrown out and now we're learning
that they didn't actually give the
defense all of the proper evidence i am
so shocked at how unethical lawyers can
be oh these guys you know when they're
nominated
doctoring evidence against donald trump
they're embezzling money and shaking
down people like avenatti and remember
those nitwits with mueller just
destroyed their iphones after that witch
hunt it's just i thought these people
were supposed to be independent actors
they're just like the rest of us they're
just a bunch of really dirty rotten
scoundrels
these are rogue
prosecutors they are rogue runaway
prosecutors and this is great
because now we can see how dastardly
they are and if you didn't have cameras
you get the press come out and lie about
what would happen in the courtroom it's
like right now if they didn't have a
window here the press would say it's
raining and then they open up the window
no rain press till tells me it's raining
that's why the country doesn't trust the
press anymore because we can see we have
the internet now we have full visibility
cameras in the courtroom you can see the
actual documents the fbi
ig reports you see there's it's a great
great time to be alive in this country
and we are just being lied to in our
faces and it's sick the way the press is
also trashing this judge
they don't like this judge because he's
supposed to be impartial the left hates
impartiality they want activists in
robes that's why every person they
appoint to the high court
is a total left winger none of the
liberal justices ever cross over to side
with the conservatives it's always the
conservative justices crossing over
because they have some semblance of
independence no no no they don't like
this guy even though this judge
appointed by a democrat and
ran for election like a bunch of times
the people put him there there was an
associated press headline today that was
frustrating with the deference the judge
had to the defendant but let's remember
you are innocent until proven guilty in
america hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else